[Music]
far away as north as we can go once
stood an enchanted forest
you see an encanta forest yes it was a
magical place but something went wrong
since then no one can get in or out that
was epic
what would I do without you
you'll always have me
[Music]
how's Elsa seemed weird to you she seems
like Elsa there's this voice voice what
does that mean
the kingdom is not safe find who is
calling to you they may have answers I'm
going with you
Anna no excuse me I climb to the North
Mountain survived a frozen heart and
saved you from my ex-boyfriend so you
know I'm coming that's normal
[Music]
where are we how did you get in the
force the mist parted for has been
possible where did you learn magic
[Music]
can't follow me in the fire then don't
run into fire
[Music]
magic is very alluring without you see
bein lose herself
protect arendelle at all cost
[Music]
I believe in you Elsa
or anything
[Music]
quick question is the whole putting up
some mortal games are gonna be a regular
thing
[Music]